Chlorine dioxide has been touted in some internet discussion circles as an effective cancer
cure, or most writings refer to it as a disinfectant. I found only one reference to it on the
clinic site and it is not sold in the store. Do you have any credible information indicating
chlorine dioxide even in small amounts as a cancer reducer? The substance usually contains
sodium chloride, so wouldn't it be poisonous even in low concentrations? Could a curative
claim be snakeling? Chlorine dioxide has also been sold as MMS, miracle, mineral solution. When
you talk about something as just like this cure-all for everything, which unfortunately, I think
was discarded. His last name is humble, which is kind of odd because he wasn't very humble, but he
went around pushing MMS, you know, as a cure-all for everything. And yes, I think it was just snake
oil-ish. I think it was really bad. But the sad thing is is, you know, in all these things,
there's some little truths to it. So when we saw a lot of line patients, I used to use MMS with
line patients, and there was some effectiveness with it. I think it had benefit. I think it does have
benefit in killing pathogens. But when you say, oh, yeah, here's the cancer treatment with MMS.
I just can't imagine the metabolic pathway that it would be working to kill cancer.
And the cancer protocol with it is so high that there could be toxic levels. And it's just really
concerned me. We took it off the store years ago. I still used to sell it in my office for a long
time for my line patients. But we took it off the store years ago because the FDA just really,
really came down on it. And I realized that sometimes when the FDA comes down on something,
it's probably a good thing to use. But I'm not a big fan of chloride dioxide for cancer. I
still think it has a lot of efficacy killing pathogens. And I think there was efficacy of it
using it for COVID in viruses. But boy, anybody who was pushing chloride dioxide during COVID was just
hammered big time by the FDA. I'm talking about clinics or physicians that were posting anything.
They're just, our country is getting worse and worse as far as what you could actually say.
We're going to be losing our YouTube channel pretty soon at these videos. We had to figure out
a different platform to post these videos about, understand we're saving all of our, all our stuff
is saved. So we're worried about losing data. But YouTube is there, they're canceling an average
of video a week of ours. Stupid erroneous things. It's just ridiculous. Their AI is picking up on
all sorts of stuff that, you know, they're canceling. Then you see some videos on just garbage on
false claims on YouTube all the time. So I have no idea what type of what they have programmed into
their AI to pick up bad videos or false claim videos. Yes, I don't think chloride dioxide has a lot
efficacy or cancer. I do think it has an efficacy for pathogens.